it is official JPMorgan Chase CEO Jamie
Dimon he who's joined the billionaire's
Club according to the Bloomberg
billionaires index he his work at
Citigroup and JP Morgan Chase has made
him a cool 1.1 billion dollars a few
bank managers accumulate that much
wealth so how did mr. Dimon do it
Bloomberg News managing editor mataji
Miller is here and Steve Ratner is still
joining us Matt he didn't win it in
Vegas no he did not
and what's really great about this story
and what's unique about this story is
that you never really see on Wall Street
bank CEOs becoming billionaires what you
see is the founders of hedge funds
founders a private equity firm sure
David tempers your Steve Schwarzman is
your Steve Cohen's aside from Sandy
Weill Jim McCain had a billion dollars
in Bear Stearns he lost it
but we really don't see a lot of Bank
CEO it's actually CEOs in general really
don't now CEO founders okay but Steve
Ballmer would be the unique example
that's right but he was not a founder
but if you went through the Bloomberg
billionaires index and you tried to
check off all the CEOs who aren't
founders you wouldn't find many of them
it's an extremely rare all right then
how do you do it well he basically went
in there and he threw banks at
consolidation I mean everybody knows the
story of him in Sandy Weill and the the
building of Citigroup and then leaving
for Bank 1 and then going JP Morgan Ames
really has been able to stick it out and
JP Morgan is up 110 percent with
dividends since he became CEO in 2005 I
didn't get quite enough of a kick at the
Cannabis when we talked about it last
hour so I want to go back to Steve with
this question about the professional
class people's eyes would fall out of
their heads if they saw a lawyer or a
doctor or an accountant become a
billionaire strictly on the basis of the
business that he or she might do alone
once upon a time and I'm rewinding the
clock maybe 50 years people thought of
corporate managers in the same way that
they thought of other professionals they
don't any longer and they don't
certainly corporate managers don't get
compensated the way that what's a cup
manager let's say CEO right somebody in
the corner office
you know as I've said I think CEO pay in
general has gotten out of control
there's no question about that when you
look at the ratio between CEO pay worker
pay the rate of increase anything you
want to look at
I do think Jamie is a little bit of an
exception as I was listening to Matt
he's a little bit of a founder he joins
sandy weill and there were two guys
sitting in you know above a store in
Baltimore starting commercial right
that's true so I think he does get some
credit for that and I think that if you
looked at some of the CEOs of goldman
sachs hank paulson lloyd blankfein if
they're not billionaires they're pretty
close so he's not completely alone up at
that level and had hank paulson not fast
in his stock to join the treasury
department when Lloyd became CEO he
almost certainly would be but there's no
doubt he would be a billionaire today
and Lloyd Blankfein if he's not a good
what is it he didn't have to pay taxes
like don't cry for me Argentina now
picture I know about this because I was
in the government you only get to not
pay taxes once in other words you can
take the stock and put an index fund or
something but then when you sell that
then you better than zero it's better
than like a 401k in other words yeah
essentially so a lot of this I mean the
source of Jamie's wealth is largely
stock and this thing cents back to this
argument that these profs right in
Jensen and Eklund Bay
made in 1976 it's the best way to run a
company is the best way to have my mic
is apparently eric has a bad microphone
so I'm gonna mind-meld and think what
his question must have been it's all
about incentivize is that the right way
do you need to incentivize see like I'm
still astounded by this argument that
you need to incentivize these people to
do the job that they were hired to do
everybody on the ranks at Goldman Sachs
they also have a lot of stock a lot of a
lot of a lot of they have a lot of stock
they have a lot of equity linked types
of compensation and I think that's good
that's what you want you want to line
them I mean all that Eric do you think
they should I mean incentive pay keeps
people fired up I mean it's sort of the
opposite of pay
at the same time also breeds some of the
worst behavior that we have seen not
just in financial services but elsewhere
right it's sort of people who get paid
and they were dangerous as soon as
people sign a contract and they know
what they're gonna be paid for the next
few years
they can sit back and they say whoa I
know what I'm getting December 31st if
there's incentive pay you are racing
around that track because you want to
get paid at the end of the year I think
Stephanie has incentive pay I would say
that there's both arguments that you can
have incentive pay because you want CEOs
to be looking at the interest of the
shareholders because the shareholders we
all own all these companies through our
401ks and through our index funds anyway
so you need to incentivize them but
whether it's a twenty million dollar
stock package or cash package doesn't
really matter these people are paid a
lot of money